my camera's not turning on
nothing
okay does this seem like a desert to you
[Music]
that's ridiculous
can you be a total [ __ ] and still
change the world for the better i'm not
actually sure about that question but
there's one guy who certainly seems like
proof that you can and you've probably
never heard his name the most
fascinating character in american
history i've never heard anything about
and yes that's john green an og youtuber
and author of the fault in our stars and
turtles all the way down and someone who
i am a giant fan of and during this
interview was sort of low-key freaking
out anyway john green wrote a book with
some very juicy and fascinating essays
link in the doobly-doo and one of those
essays is about this guy clarence
saunders
yes clarence saunders clarence saunders
changed everything at least here in the
united states and to understand how you
have to understand grocery
stores specifically what grocery stores
used to look like 100 years ago
[Music]
wait a minute before we go on let me
just tell you something really quickly
see this inside of this little case are
earbuds that i've been using lately
and the earbuds are made by raycon who
are the sponsor of today's video these
are called the everyday earbuds and as
the sun has been coming out and as i've
been sort of trying to get back to
normal i've been exercising for the
first time in a while and uh going for
runs and when i go for runs i listen to
audiobooks is that a nerdy thing that i
do i listen to audiobooks when i go for
runs anyway these earbuds have been
awesome
unlike most earbuds they don't fall out
of my ears i tend to have these like big
ear
holes and
what i love about these everyday earbuds
is that they come with different sized
like gel
fittings so i can just put the biggest
ones on and they actually like stick in
my ear and they don't fall out that's
cool the other thing is the battery life
is basically forever like it's like 32
hours of battery life which is a very
long time and they're like really
affordable they're like half the price
of premium earbuds that are out there so
they're affordable
they sound really good and they stay in
my ears and the battery lasts for a long
time so i've been going on runs i've
been listening to audiobooks with these
earbuds and i really like them raycon
comes with a 45 day happiness guarantee
like they're so confident that you're
gonna like these earbuds that they're
just like yeah try them for 45 days and
we like guarantee that you'll be happy
so if you're interested in even looking
into these
there's a link in my description by
raycon.com johnny harris please use that
link if you're going to go check these
out first off you get 15 off of these
earbuds if you do that and then also it
helps support this channel when you go
to that link so that raycon knows that
you showed up to them
through this video there's also a card
like up here somewhere that is that link
too that is technology we can put little
cards in youtube videos
welcome to the future thank you raycon
for sending me these awesome earbuds and
for
supporting this channel and for
sponsoring today's video and let's get
back to the story now clarence saunders
what a man so my great-grandfather's
grocery store in rural tennessee was
like almost every grocery store in
america it was called a full-service
grocery store you walked in there was a
counter you often handed the grocer a
list and then the grocer would go and
get all of your food and then they would
weigh it all and they would charge you
and often you would pay back
that grocery bill over time on credit
there were no aisles customers usually
didn't pick brand names so brand name
food wasn't nearly as important as it is
now and
also
highly processed packaged food wasn't
nearly as important as it is now the
first thing this guy clarence saunders
did was he had an idea he would later
like tell the origin story of many
different ways but one of the ways he
told it
he would say
i was on a train
and like a bold of lightning the idea
hit me for the future of american food
a daily battle is being waged in
supermarkets all over this country a
battle for the customer's dollar
his concept for a grocery store was a
store with aisles where customers
themselves would walk through the aisles
and pick their own food there would be
price tags on the food which had never
been the case before
and he would call this grocery store
piggly wiggly wait what piggly wiggly
piggly wiggly
why why
why
that's a great question question johnny
so
one time saunders was asked about this
and he answered the name of the grocery
store quote arrived from out of chaos
and in direct contact with an
individual's mind which
maybe gives you a little bit of a
concept of the sort of dude he was some
men
just want to watch the world burn
oh that is that is amazing but mostly
when people would ask why call your
grocery store piggly wiggly he would
answer so that people will ask that very
question
man it's like the it's like the it's
this feels like the old spice commercial
pair sherman freshmates with your shark
spice body spray is too powerful to stay
in some commercial
yes we're gonna just be like so weird
and crazy that like everyone will be
curious and a huge percentage of his
advertising budget went to ads that were
so
weird i mean he called the third piggly
wiggly piggly wiggly the third because
he felt that it was owed a certain royal
dignity i mean it was very much like the
early 1920s and 30s version of the old
spice ads
okay so clarence saunders basically just
disrupted the old way of grocery
shopping and as a consequence a bunch of
clerks these people who used to do the
grocery shopping lost their job my
great-grandfather's grocery store closed
as did many many others a lot of jobs
were lost in this and and there was
widespread fear about you know losing
jobs to automation losing jobs to hyper
efficiency
which also of course foreshadows some
current concerns technology today could
lead to 45 of current jobs disappearing
but that doesn't make him an [ __ ]
like there are people all the time
making businesses that people lose jobs
on and we sort of freak out about it but
it's actually better for the world oh
and he was pioneering new ways of like
guerrilla marketing that made people
talk about him more which was a really
cool thing too seems like this guy
changed the world for the better and he
did but he also starts to give us signs
of who he really is
[Music]
so even early on there were some
indications that saunders was
a bully that he could be very cruel to
employees that he could shortchange
partners and he was obsessed with growth
he was obsessed with making piggly
wiggly as big as possible as fast as
possible taking over the entire world in
fact even when piggly wiggly was a
memphis only phenomenon in the very
early days he would put on the windows
outside the store piggly wiggly all over
the world
so this gets to my question as someone
who is building a startup right now and
thinking a lot about building a company
i genuinely have this question do you
really need to be the mean bully founder
and boss to make a world-changing
business we'll try to answer that
question in a little bit but first i
gotta tell you the next part of the
clarence saunders story because it's
just too good not to tell
this is where we start to see a lot of
the negatives of clarence saunders he
became obsessed with trying to prove
these wall street speculators wrong
and as he lost control of the business
he became more and more angry and
vitriolic and really hateful
uh he wrote about this at times quite
beautifully like once he wrote they have
it all everything i built the greatest
stores of their kind in the world but
they didn't get the man that was father
to the idea they have the body of piggly
wiggly but they didn't get the soul and
i just love that i mean
how much do you have to believe in
yourself to be like i am the soul of
this company so his next idea isn't
quite the same as the original piggly
wiggly it's actually much closer to
contemporary grocery stores because
there are still aisles where people pick
out a lot of their own food but there
are also staffed counters for the delhi
department and for the bakery as he's
developing this new idea he wants to
call the grocery store saunders because
of course he does but the people who own
piggly wiggly are like no no no no you
are not allowed to use your name in
selling a grocery store because that
would be a direct competitor to piggly
wiggly and that is a violation of our
agreements
and in response clarence saunders
decided to call his new grocery store
the clarence saunders sole owner of my
name grocery store oh my gosh it's so
good it's like i didn't realize you
could one the sort of self-centeredness
and like snarkiness of this guy
and it's just like
and it's like it's like again he's doing
this to his business like this is what
is going to be out there to the world
and yet he's using it as
personal
he's like personal like ego fest i love
it but that's a lot of what we see with
21st century capitalism too is these
highly charismatic individual founders
who are really lifted up as the
centerpiece of the company that it's not
about the 75 000 or 200 000 employees
working together on a project it's about
this one god man
you know almost always a man
my question is now for you as the
as a person who's grown
businesses and and has led people
and i'm in this now more and more as i
grow like a startup and stuff and like
clarence saunders was obviously very
successful like timing might have been a
little bit off but like he was very
successful in disrupting and changing
things and building a business that
still exists today do you have to be an
[ __ ] to like build big businesses in
in in the capitalistic system like is
that is that a prerequisite to like be
hyper successful
in your mind i'm not sure i was
on a phone call once with a very
successful
entrepreneur person
and he said to me
you're too loyal to your people and not
loyal enough to your product and my
feeling about that was well if that's
the side that we're gonna air on that's
the side i would prefer to air on like
i i believe in humans making stuff
together i don't really believe in the
idea of these
suey generous
brilliant individuals who reshape
history on their own i mean the truth is
like
almost every successful person clarence
saunders was
a bubble on the tide of empire as robert
penn warren put it he was riding a wave
that was
much much larger than him
and
i i mean he was a very bright guy
but i i think that in the end
that obsession with growth at all costs
that obsession
with
you know winning
it ruined him i mean he died
he died a poor man
in a
sanitarium for mentally ill people he
alienated almost everyone who loved him
in his life and
i don't i don't think that's the hero's
journey
[Music]